you know what we've been watching is the
Wii this weekend we needed some some
stupid to put on like in the background
when you're just chilling mm-hmm so we
put on paradise hotel
oh yeah it's like the love island ripoff
yeah which they just ripped it off
completely it's so shameless dude they
have like a like a cheeky British
narrator even and it's a [ __ ]
American show I'm upset and they do it
in the exact same way it's like well you
know while Janet and whatever are down
here better let's check in with our two
Americans not what it's to Americans uh
the people on the show are American and
the host is American the host is Kristin
Cavallari who she was from the hills are
from Laguna Beach or something
mmm she's got her own reality show now
she's like kind of famous but it's just
like a shameless shameless ripoff and
it's unbelievable how much more
Americans suck than British people yeah
like on shows like this yeah like
someone said that before they were like
don't have it they're like you the
Americans are gonna ruin love island
it's not gonna be the same mm-hmm and
now after watching this show I'm like a
little bit a little part of me is like
damn its kind of true like they're just
not as like charming or cheeky you're
like the flirting like isn't as cool to
watch
nice sucks it's like ah it's awkward and
the people that if I nurse to dumb
almost it's just like ah ruining it yeah
because in charisma even though you know
the English love island people are
supposed to be the garbage people of the
UK there is still something charming
about them yeah and like it I don't know
what it is but uh maybe it's the accent
I don't know maybe it's a slang via
definitely man it's a chat here's the
chat rose the chat is the chat yeah I
can only imagine the American flirting
just terrible Americans it's actually
probably like watching someone play The
Sims yeah yeah yeah well honey
Rula it kind of is what the [ __ ] are
they even dogs just like dudes that are
just way too like like trying to
convince people at their alpha yeah you
know yeah I feel like the British do
just know
let it ride there's like I'm acting
hottest [ __ ] yeah the Americans all have
like this weird like chip on their
shoulder or somewhere that's what it
like and they just sort of like this and
then so we have a connection right and
just don't say it like that don't just
say it like like charmer a little bit
what are you yeah I feel like honestly
if I'm gonna be honest with you I kind
of feel like we have a connection and I
just like to see where this pans out oh
yeah just insecure yeah y'all insecure
rip this [ __ ] it's accurate so like
we're good right there's one of the
[ __ ] guy he's on it has a stuffed
animal and on the second day started
crying to his to his girl about how he's
like misunderstood or something
that's what it is dude nice you know
what it is Americans are we're all on
opiates and and that kind of we're on
opiates and we're the product of divorce
and there's all kinds of internalized
bad [ __ ] English people might have but
they just is the I feel like they're
kind of blunt about [ __ ] yeah like yeah
my mom and they split and Charles like
hooked on on drugs for a little bit I'm
alright now it's like very kind of like
yet like it is what it is yeah and and
this buff guy on the shows got the
stuffed animal and he's just fresh off a
xanax and he's just like what can I
don't get me man and my dad used to be
exactly like it's like the British
people are like the world sucks but I'm
hot and I'm just gonna try and relax and
enjoy the kids Americans are like the
world's awesome amiracle rules I'm
[ __ ] it's mine for the take and I'm
gonna take it but like I'm not sure
myself yeah it also I'm a little bit
afraid that everyone thinks I have a
little bit of a gun in here
I'm really [ __ ] buff I'm really
afraid people are gonna notice the
little piece of gut thing on the top of
my speedo right here okay one of the
girls one of the girls is straight up a
bottle
from Tucson nice like she's exactly like
one of the girls I was describing in in
Scottsdale that's her
that is so funny she's just like just
the very first day she's like her and
this her and this dude like start Mackin
right there they have like a good
connection as that you know their words
not mine
right and and so they're like they seem
like they're getting along great they're
sleeping in the same bed they're hooking
up whatever and this new guy comes in
and she's like oh I got a plan and he's
like yeah what's her plan and she's like
I'm gonna Mack on the new guy so that he
picks me oh no sorry I'm gonna Mack on
him so that he doesn't Makani one else
so that he thinks that he's definitely
in it with me so that we can just
eliminate him cut the fat and hit the
guys like I guess seems like a sure you
think I thought we like why don't we
just keep doing our thing I think you
got to go over there and make out with
him and that's exactly what she does and
now that guy's gonna go right on a forum
somewhere women are and yeah or he's
just gonna further it even more what's
wrong with me exactly
that's hilarious oh so what'd she do she
went over there she took him on a date
she makes out with him okay and then she
comes back and she goes yeah I did it I
made out with them and the guys like
nice we got yeah we got like dude
weighted cocked yeah like 4chan picture
of LoJack yeah with the smiling a behind
cool yes a little good plan yeah we got
them in the palm of our hand right where
we want them you'll never see it coming
yet I never see it coming that's that's
I mean good on her I guess yeah maybe
she is smarter than I think she's gone
what she wants all 19 of her brain cells
firing oh [ __ ] I got it which is one of
those shows where you're watching and
you're like this is [ __ ] every memory
moment you're like this is trash this is
trash yeah and you're like let's
definitely watch the next episode yeah
see what happens yeah but a lot violent
I don't get that feel of violent I'm
like engaged yeah like I like it starts
next week I know and perhaps we will be
mm-hmm
I didn't say anything what I don't I
also not anonymous well we'll see we'll
see
[Music]